in the San Antonio Spurs in developing
their young talent not just about
getting the top jacket as you see one of
those guys that develop it knocks it
down from feet I think about as I was
getting whatever shot I wanted and just
couldn't make anything Walker when three
seconds goes up I'll laugh it in how
about those two demos he's showing off a
little bit his his talent beautiful
cross over there and then a blur and the
open court beautiful finished he's dying
in the game have gone to the Wizards to
make them look a little bit more
respectable
[Applause]
south back in the 30s and 40s and 50s in
it to see some of the pictures and some
of the stuff they had on display really
brought it sharply into focus on a
rebound San Antonio the other way now by
7:00 trying to close the gap here late
in the first quarter Ledbetter likes
that three ball as well and puts it down
to the quarter rim and Walker with the
rebound
Walker's in another gear right now
three's up good Wow and you kind of felt
it was coming Walker again picking up
the loose ball Walter in 22 and a half
points of a GBB walk harass another
indeed live pump just Walker Walker
floats it up off the window plus the
foul beautifully done by Lonnie Walker
okay I talk about this all the time the
patience is so important you see how he
kind of delay the conditioning has to be
far better skill level I've got to
improve upon zion Williamson shooting
the basketball
[Music]
and totally locked in will happen he's
failing it his entire career little
turnaround jump shot good hustle to get
back by Walker Walker's a good athlete
they've got some good athletes at that
guard position and Brynn puts it up in
it
Mills on the pickup for San Antonio not
going to get you up top a lot Walker put
up big numbers in the summer league for
the games that he played this is what he
is capable of doing nice drop off the
one hand already got a season-high
tonight
[Music]
they got it going tonight it's the
three-ball three seconds to go Lonnie
Walker trying to make it happen into in
[Applause]
exhale and assume that she's won the
game and then start getting down to on
with your passes in private row seat
here this pulls it through right and
down the middle and I know the Knicks
weren't expecting that they probably
just thought he was gonna lay it up I
don't know
Lonnie but how about this one ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
they have seats when we introduce two
starting lineups of LaMarcus Aldridge
got a Storify and was out tonight
obviously this firs have missed him
he's the decent honest Rivers is at a
ricocheted off of hurdle didn't go
through any fakes
Wooga speed wall there
[Music]
garland change of pace
Lonnie Walker knocking it away there's
no bubble burst
there's Ruby helping out Ruby us coming
off the season high 22 you in there
Memphis boss
Loni walkers nearly lost the handle
scores out of control he he had it well
within in hand they will absorb the
contact smash into Sarge very focused
[Applause]
he's run the floor he catches this on
the run you can really see how high he
gets off at this angle and the fact that
he's able to catch that ball from
outside but my guess is he's going to
try to come in and play inside the game
[Applause]
no one puts a body on Lonnie Walker and
he's flying in there and it's an easy
putback Derek Wright takes that off the
rim
[Music]
[Applause]
hey he's pushing the page until
someone's gonna stop him tops it off to
Lani Walker well ahead of the peeled the
final seven seconds with hurdle pushing
ahead Walker will gather
[Applause]
beat the clothes has come to the boss
Charlie who kissed the ball nonchalantly
with one hand go to the ball strongly
catch it with two hands get a strong
faith is dangerous on the drive first
come away as Pirtle gives it off the
derrick light Mills trailing the play is
he got knocked down by troll with the
stuff just to play the passing lane
perfectly mana gets this chance to show
off going top shelf
[Applause]
on a flips to Derrick white girl went
off and left him then they covered into
the paint and one for Lonnie Walker them
to determine drive there from Lonnie to
dribble there it is right there he's but
a flick more on the floor
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
show you that play
Lonnie turned on the Jets that is a
masterpiece